la stratégie elle est au coeur des
campagnes électorales la source
probablement de beaucoup d'insomnie chez
les conseillers des chefs
on a donc décidé pour les prochaines
semaines d'essayer de lever le voile sur
le mystère des stratégies des partis
politiques et j'ai invité trois stratège
des vrais pas des ex à venir à jaser
avec nous ils ont les mains dans tous
les jours avec moi catherine loubier
conseillère pour le québec de stephen
harper robert asselin conseiller de
justin trudeau et karl bélanger
conseiller stratégique principal de
thomas mulcair bonjour à vous trois on
va faire une mise en garde à nos
auditeurs on peut pas vous demander en
campagne électorale de venir ici puis
jauger la performance de vos chefs ça va
descendre qu'on appelle les lignes de
voir les lignes
alors on a vraiment décidé de voir sous
un autre angle idée de prendre un peu de
recul peut-être sur les stratégies ce
qui anime les décisions des partis
politiques la première qui suppose une
campagne en était tout le monde quand la
campagne commencée d'une campagne dans
l'été les gens écouteront postes doivent
changer la façon dont fait campagne
catherine va commencer avec vous c'est
vous qui avez fait ce pari là bas on a
fait ce pari là parce que entre autres
le chef du npd était en campagne depuis
déjà deux semaines c'était important
pour nous que ce soit les partis
politiques qui paient pour les élections
et non les canadiens à pour ce qui est
de la campagne en est et ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que les gens pensent
avec l'argent qu'ils ont dans les poches
comment je vais faire pour payer mes
vacances cet été
j'ai la rentrée scolaire qui arrive à y
pense même au delà de ça à noël donc je
pense que ça les préoccupe au plus haut
point les questions d'économie d'argent
dans leurs poches
même s'ils sont moins attentifs que
qu'ils le seront d'ici un mois peut-être
dans quelques semaines mais tous les
partis avaient comme un peu mais les
deux routes avait des parties cop16
cette semaine là constamment sa 11e mais
tandis que ça change la façon dont fait
campagne et et les gens sont pas au même
endroit que ça change pour pour
l'instant moi ce que je vois c'est
exactement la même chose le rythme est
aussi freiné aussi fort aussi intense
pour la simple et bonne raison que on
peut pas laisser les autres partis font
campagne pineau dire c'est l'été on
rester à la maison on va les cueillir
des fraises tout ça alors évidemment on
est tous sa campagne c'est une campagne
d'aix est déclenché il tout le monde
était à pleine vapeur mais moi je vais
vous dire je trouve ça génial
pourquoi je trouve ça génial parce que
il fait beau les journées sont longues
et doit on va voir les gens on se
promène un peu partout dans le pays
alors hiver est absolument que ça donne
beaucoup plus de possibilités aussi en
termes de d'événements qu'on peut faire
on peut aller dans les festivals on peut
aller là où les gens se trouvent l'été
alors nous qui accompagnons le chef moi
personnellement j'aime bel vac enfin
lille et pkp l'hiver quand il fait moins
trente meilleurs rythmes à jauger dans
une campagne aussi longue certains ont
dit cette campagne lost un peu comme une
partie d'accueil trois périodes est ce
que vous pensez ça oui en théorie dans
huit jours on aurait terminé une
campagne électorale
il reste deux donc effectivement fort et
qu'il brille tout faut équilibrer le
budget assurer d'abord une crise
budgétaire pour de la crème solaire et
il faut s'assurer de guerre rodez la
machine pour que les canadiens vont
vraiment regarder et écouter ce qui se
passe
ceci dit des bulletins de nouvelles
continues et les cotes des coups de
sonde or il ya des gens qui regardent
s'intéresse à ça et on peut pas se
permettre d'abandonner ou de laisser ça
allait il faut vraiment paire formée dès
le départ maintenant dans les campagnes
électorales et mise en scène on a monté
quelques images pour montrer à nos
auditeurs
justin trudeau pour parler des
infrastructures cette semaine était avec
son chapeau libéral au volant d'une
volant est ce qu'on peut dire ça une
grue quand même il faut le faire
après si on a vu monsieur harper lui
dans un autre ordre d'idées lui qu'on
juge des fois froid faire l'épicerie
avec sa famille allait commander des
ailes de poulet pour eux pour ses
enfants et monsieur mulcair lui qui dans
une usine à fait la cie du xylophone des
meubles sérieusement ce peu factice
s'est mise en scène je vous ai reçu
trudeau va pas les faire de la grue
monsieur le fric est refait pas du
xylophone ans les unes qu'est ce que ça
change parce que ça marche vraiment une
journée type commence par une annonce
habituellement et en après midi
régulièrement on donne de la couleur
pour permettre aux journalistes télé ou
bien télé de bien visualiser de quoi on
parle et c'est ce qui se passe
maintenant
mais pour nous que vous faites c'est ça
sert les intérêts des partis politiques
presse que sa chance et a dit que ça
sert un narratif qu'on essaie d'établir
l'important politique cdu
lisez ce qu'on est en train d'essayer de
dire aux gens alors quand on met
qu'enfin une annonce économique c'est
important que les gens comprennent
qu'est-ce qu'on essaie véhicule est
vraiment comme message qu'est ce que ça
m'a chargé de prouver qu'elle juste être
doivent pas opérer une grue mon nom mais
tout le monde a compris que c'était une
annonce pour les infrastructures et des
infrastructures ont les batifoler bâtir
donc l'image pas cet effort les gens on
a vu monsieur après au début de la
campagne parler d'environnement il est
allé dans un beau des cas où il y avait
mon dessin nous on voyait
l'environnement derrière lui une belle
montagne cours d'eau tout ça alors ça ça
fait partie de ce que toutes les
campagnes que cette femme dans une phase
où la durée d'où les enfants pourquoi
cette fois ci permettait sur l'image je
pense que c'est important parce que les
gens s'alimente sur leur téléphone
intelligent un concept des images alors
si le volume la télé est fermée où il
passe sur un le fil twitter ou le fil
facebook
il s'alimente en premier sur facebook
maintenant pour l'information donc pour
cette raison l image qui vaut mieux le
mot le médium c'est le message est
extrêmement important les enfants on
parle d'une campagne de 78 jours pour
monsieur un peu d'avoir sa femme ses
enfants avec lui jusqu'à ce qu'ils
retournent à l'école du moins c'est
extrêmement important parce que
évidemment il ya un temps pour être
sérieux dans la journée mais l'inter ne
s'est pas passé de bons moments en
famille donc
pour lui c'est la priorité parce que
monsieur mulcair est accompagné de son
épouse aussi assez souvent son niveau
ses fils sont venus faire un tour sur la
campagne et ça sera le cas pendant toute
la durée de la campagne évidemment c'est
important pour les chefs qu'ils soient
là ces gens là pourquoi il est important
pour des raisons humaines il faut que
leurs familles les accompagnent c'est
les gens avec lesquels ils sont le plus
près dans leur vie de tous les jours à
la part de famille c'est important est
avec ses enfants avec sa conjointe son
épouse pour lui c'est important mais
aussi ça le reste comme on dit en bon
français grande est important qu'ils
gardent ce lien le très près avec avec
les gens qu'il aime les gens qui
côtoient tous les jours
les électeurs rencontrés un peu la
famille des chefs savoir qui est ce on
me contacte connaître la personne
derrière le politicien lorsqu'on se
promène
évidemment je suis le gars est souvent
et les chefs si le programme ad autres
sont envahis personnes nées de la dame
où le fils et il n'a pas une idée
d'aller rencontrer monsieur le gavia la
famille et pour les électeurs pour les
gens c'est très important
il reste 30 secondes mais juste montré
vite à nos auditeurs on les appelle
c'est dérogatoire un pue mais les
plantes vers bourg décor les gens
derrière les chefs
comment vous les choisissez catherine le
bag drop humains comme on dit dans le
langage n'est pas toujours ce qu'on
choisit de faire pour un événement ça
peut être la machinerie parce qu'on veut
lancer un message de commerce d'économie
où ça peut être effectivement la nature
quand on veut quand on veut parler de la
nature mais le bac groupe humain il ya
des gens qui nous écrivent qu'ils nous
appellent tous les jours pour me dire
écoutez si vous avez besoin de quelqu'un
qui veut parler du droit des victimes
par exemple pour le gouvernement
conservateur
on va venir avec vous on va venir vous
accompagner durant une annonce donc des
parties prenantes et des gens qui qui
veulent se faire voir avec nous et
défendre les causes avec nous et souvent
c'est comme cette série je pense la
règle de l'art c'est le respect c'est la
personne ne veut venir dans une mise en
scène volontaire c'est c'est à elle de
décider
photo m -ca un fou du puy vue classe
mais c'est intéressant
visuel plus accrocheur évidemment ça
comporte des risques au monde vu dans la
campagne conservateur lorsque les
partisans se met à en garder les
journées mais ça devient intéressant ça
renforce le message des fonds de des
pompiers des fois des candidats et ont
permis aux gens de visualiser le message
non m'avoue 3 je vous remercie d'avoir
été des nôtres on a brisé la glace puis
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
merci